This morning we're going to begin
making the transition from the classical
utilitarian doctrine of Jeremy Bentham's
to the neoclassical doctrine that was
championed by a number of different
figures in the late 19th and early 20th
century. And we're going to end up
by focusing on John Stuart Mill,
um,
as the principal expository of
neoclassical utilitarianism.
And where are we headed is for a
doctrine that I'm going to call the right
utility synthesis,
the reits utilities synthesis signals
that we're looking for an attempt to put
together both a commitment too,
utilitarian efficiency that's grounded
in science and on the one hand and
respect for individual rights that's
grounded in the workmanship ideal.
On the other hand,
and we're not going to actually get to
the reits utilities synthesis as it's
expressed in politics by John
Stuart Mill until next Monday.
What instead I'm going to
do today is explain how the,
the transition from classical
to neoclassical utilitarianism,
um,
really went on in all fields of thinking
about the human sciences at more or
less the same time.
There were developments in Pol political
theory that we're going to talk about
at considerable length,
but there will also, um,
undergirding that developments
in economics and in
philosophy that are going to
be my principal focus in today's lecture.
What you're also going to get as a
byproduct of today's lecture is everything
you ever needed to know about
neoclassical economics in 45 minutes.
That is to say a neoclassical economics
is a brilliant intellectual creation to
a large extent the creation
of bill freight out Pareto,
an Italian economist that I'm
going to talk about today. Um,
but with the important contributions from
other figures in the modern history of
economics such as Marshall
a and, w I'm going to, uh,
it's mentioned in some
detail and economist called
Edgeworth and they developed
a system of,
of,
of thinking about economics and the
theory of value that was going to be
tremendously influential and important.
Um,
not only in the way
utilitarianism involved,
but in the way of our
thinking about markets.
Legitimacy and distributive justice
would evolve at the same time,
more or less.
There were very important developments
in moral philosophy that I just want to
alert you to,
that we're going to return to later when
we come to consider Alistair McEntire's
book after virtue. And this, um,
movement in philosophy that I'm,
I'm mentioning here is the doctrine that
would come to be called emotive Islam.
It was associated with a man
by the name of Stephenson, uh,
who, who wrote several books
advocating the emotive as doctrine,
uh, when he was an untenured professor
in the Yale philosophy department as a
byproduct of which he never became a
tenured professor in the Yale Philosophy
Department because his doctrine
was thought to be so repugnant.
His doctrine was that when we
make claims like murder is wrong,
um,
we are making claims that express
our emotions are emotive reactions to
propositions.
Just as when we say,
I like ice cream or I prefer chocolate
ice cream to strawberry ice cream,
all we're doing is expressing our tastes,
our emotional reactions,
and that there is nothing more
to say about ethics than that.
Now you could say this,
this emotive as doctrine is a,
an end point in an philosophical
evolution that really begins in the 17th
century.
Hobbs who I mentioned to you in a very
first lecture criticized Aristotle for
not seeing as Hobbes thought that what
is desirable for some people is not
desirable for others.
Um,
but Hobbs didn't truth be told,
take that view that seriously
because he thought for the most part,
we're all pretty much the same.
And if you look at the other
classical utilitarians like, um,
um, David Hume who were
not reading in this course,
but we could read in this
course or Sidgwick who were
not reading in this course,
but we could have read in this course.
They also basically thought human beings
were more or less all alike in their
psychological structure,
in their basic human needs.
Human has a famous line somewhere to
the effect that if all factual questions
were resolved,
no moral questions would remain.
If all factual questions were resolved,
And it's not that human thought.
We could derive an ort statement from
an is Hume's famous for the idea that an
ort cannot be derived from an is
that there's a fact value problem.
Um, but he, he thought nonetheless,
people are pretty much the same.
And so if you can figure out
what makes one of them check,
you can figure out what
makes all of them tick.
And that was most emphatically
Jeremy Bentham's view. Uh,
it's opposed in everything
we discussed last time.
If you think about the idea of doing
interpersonal comparisons of utility,
um,
and making the judgment that taking that
dollar from Donald Trump and giving it
to the bag lady increases her
utility more than it decreases his,
you're assuming that they basically
all have the same kinds of utility
functions.
Stevenson questioned that idea radically.
He said,
we don't actually know.
We should take obs much more seriously
in his critique of Aristotle then he was
willing to take himself.
We don't actually know if people have
the same kinds of utility functions.
We don't know whether or not what makes
some people happy will make others happy
as well.
And so Stevenson was thought to be a
proponent of a kind of moral relativism
because he linked ethics to
our desires and preferences,
any emotions and nothing else.
And then he said,
it's actually an open question.
Stevenson was criticizing
Hume on this point,
but he might as well have been
criticizing Hobbs or Bentham.
Stephen's had said it's an open question
whether people are like in their basic
psychological structures in there,
in there the physiology
of their human needs.
And so that was thought to be a
radically relativist doctrine because it,
it seemed to undermine
the possibility of making,
um, ethical judgements of
any sword across people.
That is a doctrine to which
we will return. As I said,
when we get to,
uh,
the Anti Enlightenment and in particular
Alistair McEntire's book after virtue.
But today we're going to focus for the
rest of our time on the economics of the
transition from classical to
neoclassical utilitarianism.
And I'm going to ask you to suspend
disbelief for the rest of today's lecture
and just trust me.
Because what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go into this backwards.
I'm going to come into the transition
from classical to neoclassical economics.
Um,
by looking at a very different problem
that the neoclassical economists were
concerned with that had nothing to
do with utilitarianism or rights will
anything that we've been
talking about in this lecture.
And it's not until you get to the end
of this narrative that you will start to
see why the transition from classical
to neoclassical utilitarianism in
economics was essential for the transition
in political theory and indeed for
the transition in moral
philosophy. So, uh, as I said,
you're going to have to suspend your
disbelief and just follow me through the
ABC of neoclassical price theory,
which is what we're going to do now.
And as I said, the bow, the bonus here,
the byproduct is you're going to get
the whole of econ one o one reduced to a
single lecture because indeed it is true
that enormously complex and subtle and
sophisticated as the neo classical
theory of micro economics is,
it's all belt out of three ideas.
It's all built out of the three ideas
that I'm going to spell out for you,
uh, in what some of you might initially
go regardless, laborious and detail.
Um, but I'm gonna do it anyway. Uh,
and I think you'll see
what I'm getting at. Um,
once we get towards the
end of today's discussion,
so
imagine a single person,
we're going to call them a as testimony
to my lack of imaginative invest,
but you could call them anything you like.
Um,
and let's imagine a world in which
they're just two commodities in this guy's
wine and bread.
The system of neoclassical utilitarianism
invented by Paredo says that other
things being equal, you want more rather
than less. Um, any source of utility,
right? We know that from
classical utilitarianism. Um,
but if you have,
if you have six bottles of wine
and only one loaf of bread bread is
comparatively more
valuable to you than wine,
so that you would exchange a lot of
wine to get a second loaf of bread.
If on the other hand,
uh,
you would choking on your six loaves
of bread and dying of thirst, uh, the,
the reverse would be
true and you would be,
you would give up a lot of bread in
order to get a small amount of wine and
these,
these are what are called indifference
curves and neoclassical economics and
indifference curves basically
imply exactly as the name
suggests that you would
be indifferent among the mixes of
bread and wine anywhere on this curve.
And this curve is always shaped that way.
Concave toward the origin.
Anybody wanting to tell us why
somebody who, what is it reflecting,
why is it,
why is it that shape?
Someone who's done an econ class or
somebody who remembers Monday's lecture?
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
It reflects the idea of diminishing
marginal utility reflects the idea of
diminishing marginal utility in exactly
the sense that I just said that if you
have a huge amount of bread,
the next loaf of bread is less
valuable to you at the margin.
Then the previous loaf of bread was,
so if you've got a lot of bread,
you'll give up a lot of brand in all
the order to get a small amount of wine.
Okay? So that is the idea of
diminishing marginal utility. And when,
when we call this what I've labeled here,
I won and indifference curve,
we were saying literally you would get
the same amount of utility no matter
where you were on that curve. So
if you have one of, we have here,
this isn't very well drawn,
but uh,
say four bottles of wine
and two loaves of bread,
you would be equally happy as if
you had, um, what does it look like?
Have four loaves of bread and,
and one and a quarter bottle of wine.
You would be equally happy between
those two distributions. Okay.
What would increase your happiness?
What would increase your happiness would
be to get onto a higher indifference
curve. If you could have more bread and
more wine, of course you'd be happier.
Right?
And so the idea of of indifference
curves is that you want to go this way,
you want and go from p toward cue.
You want to get onto,
as they put it in the jargon
of neoclassical theory,
you want to get onto as
high an indifference curve
as you can possibly get.
So you're this, and this is for
those of you who like the jargon,
this would be a utility function. You want
to get up, go up your utility function,
all the way to Q. If you could, we
don't know where Q is out in the, uh,
in the stratosphere,
but any,
wherever you were on
your utility function,
you could draw one of these curves
through it. In principle, you could,
you could find, so if you
know, if you were here,
you could find the mix of bread and
wine in each instance among which you're
going to be indifferent. So that is
the notion of an indifference curve.
Now,
an important consideration in the theory
of indifference curves was to say that
we don't know,
I've,
I've put these equally apart,
but in a way I shouldn't
have because it's misleading.
If you get from one to two and
then you get from two to three
you haven't increased your utility
necessarily by the same amount.
These distances don't mean anything.
Okay. I could have put three right here
because the system of
neoclassical utilitarianism,
unlike the system of
classical utilitarianism,
works with ordinal scales,
ordered all mathematical
styles and as the word implies,
it means all we do is rank order.
We rank order our preferences,
but the we,
we don't say anything more.
So this individual a prefers 43 three
to two and two to one but we can't say
that he prefers was she prefers four
to three more than she prefers three to
two.
We don't know that.
We don't have a cardinal scale.
Remember that in Bentham
system we had cardinal scales.
We were thinking of sort of lumps of
utility that could be picked up and moved
around and we it to people,
right?
The neoclassical economists didn't want
to do that and they didn't want to do
that for a different,
a different reason than anything
I've talked about in these lectures.
They didn't want to do that because they
were actually concerned with a quiet
another problem.
The problem they wanted to solve was
to understand the behavior of markets.
They want it to be able to more precisely
to predict what prices we're going to
be in markets and they wanted
to do that for reasons.
I'm going to elaborate too much later
on when we come and talk about Marx and
the Labor theory of value
and its its limitations. Um,
but that that's for a future lecture.
For today's lecture,
all you need to concern yourself with
is the fact that they want it to be able
to understand the nature of
markets of how market prices move,
but they want it to be able to do this
with as little information as possible.
They realized that for Bentham
system to work, for example,
the government would have to have a kind
of utility tolmatter and run around and
sticking it out into people's tongues
to measure their utility, right?
Very intrusive ad you need a lot of
information to do Bentham system.
They want it to say,
how can we develop a well articulated
theory of market prices based on as little
information about people and their
preferences as possible and Paredo and
Marshall and Edgeworth and others who
are in their circle thought you could do
this just with ordinal utility.
So moving from cardinal to ordinal
utility is going to turn out to have huge
ideological consequences which
I'm going to for you, uh,
towards the end of today's lecture.
But as an analytic matter,
looking at this from the inside,
it had the,
the great virtue of the providing the
building blocks for a theory of price
behavior in market systems that required
almost no information about people.
All we would know about
this person a as I said,
is that they prefer four to three, three
to two to two, one, one, two, zero.
But we can't say anything about how much
they prefer those things because these
distances don't actually mean anything.
All we get is an ordered ranking.
Now there is one other thing we can say.
One other thing we can say,
okay
is that this is a no,
no.
These indifference curves cannot cross.
Can anybody tell us why?
Why can't they cross?
Wait for the mic?
Because at the intersection they should
have the same utility even though
they're different in
different indifference curves.
So what would happen if, what
would be what? What, what's,
what's the problem with,
I mean you're on the right track and
what's the problem with that crossing?
Because you say I too as utility of
two I 2.5 as utility of two point by,
but at that point where they intersect,
they both have to have the same utility.
So you've got a kind of contradiction
on your hands, is that right? Yeah.
Okay.
And just just to spell out the
contradiction more emphatically,
I think you basically made the point if
we're saying that we're in different,
among all of the things on this
curve and we're in different,
among all the things on this curve,
we can't,
we can't have a cross because
then we're saying here, right?
2.5 is preferred to two,
but here we're saying the opposite.
We're saying two is preferred to 2.5 okay.
The jargon.
Anybody just happen to know, yell
it out. We don't need the mic.
Does anybody know that jargon for this
France activity? The preferences,
I was assumed to be transferred in.
So if you prefer a two B and B to c,
you must prefer a to z.
That's all that transit. That means, okay,
if you prefer a two B and B two c,
it must be the case that
you also prefer a to see.
Otherwise you're contradicting
the principle of transitivity.
Okay?
So we cannot have these indifference
curves crossing one another.
Now
what we're going to do here instead of
one person and two commodities,
we're going to think about two people,
okay? We're putting, we're creating
a diagram with two people on it.
And this is I say as I promised
you earlier in the semester,
anything I do with a diagram
I will also do verbally.
So if you find this in any way confusing,
um,
just listen to their narrative and then
we'll see whether you get it that way.
Um, but so now we have a diagram
with two people on it. Okay?
So this is person a and this
is person B and these axes,
the x axis here is A's utility function.
Remember Aa and the previous slide
was trying to get from Pete towards Q,
right?
Hey was trying to go up here.
So this on this slide is the
same thing as this on this slide.
So A's trying to go this way
and B is trying to go this way,
okay?
And what we imagine is some
distribution of utility between them.
So a has this much utility f
if this is the status quo x,
okay, hey has this master utility
and B has this much, you tell them
ace, happy than be right. Wrong.
He's not,
we don't know that A's happy than before.
What I'm from what I just
said, right? These distances
don't mean anything, right?
So, uh, it looks like A's happier
than be, but that's misleading. If,
if the different distances I've taken to
imply in your mind that A's happy than
be uh, this abuse yourself
of that thought right away.
Okay? So we have a
distribution here, okay?
Now what Paredo said,
he said,
let's draw a line north,
south through the status quo,
and let's draw a line east, west
through the status quo. Okay?
And we'll imagine that there's a finite
source of utility that's called the Po.
It's gets called in the ECON textbox
the Predo possibility frontier.
So there's not an infinite
source of utility. Now
paredo said, well, if we draw the
north, south and the east west,
we get four quadrants, we get this
one, we get this one, we get this one,
and then we get this one right.
And what parade said is,
well that's interesting because we
can say different things about them.
One thing we can say is if you go
anywhere into the northeast quadrant,
both of them are better off,
right? So if we go from x to Y,
we know a, as you tell it,
he's gone up and we know bees
you, Tony's gone up, right?
We don't know by how much,
but we know it's gone up.
So that both better off. On the other
hand, if we went in anywhere in here,
this quadrant south west,
as it were,
obviously that both better at worse off.
Okay.
Because if we,
if I had put a point here,
you know Q, well no,
that's not used to Jay.
Um, that's not you. Yeah. And
let's use J by a point here, Jay.
We would say that A's gone down.
Ed Bee's gone down.
Now to make this a bit more real,
imagine
in here,
this is the sphere of market transactions.
This is where a and B will
go voluntarily, right? So A,
we'll say to be, well I have all this
wine and you have all that bread.
How about I swap you a bottle of wine
for a loaf of bread? And you're saying,
okay, you give it to them. Both
people are better off. Okay.
And we know that both better off because
they did it voluntarily and we know
they're both trying to get onto is high
and in different score as possible.
Right? So they met, they swapped the wine,
they swapped the bread and both of
them are happier, a little more tipsy.
But also a, a little, uh,
a little better fat. Okay.
Uh,
move into here
would be a ZF.
The government taxes them both
and uses the money to spend on,
um, foreign aid to a
country they both despise,
let's say.
So they both paid attacks and the money
has gone to something they don't support.
We can say that's what,
that, that's Paredo inferior,
righto. Superior or
righto inferior. Right.
It's Baredo inferior because
they both don't want it.
And both of them would resist it
if the government tried to do it.
Obviously they wouldn't go there to a
market transaction because it reduce,
it puts both of them on a
lower indifference curve. Okay.
So that's all well and good.
Well that leaves these two other quadrants
and about those two quadrants,
Pareto's says,
we can say nothing at all.
We can say nothing at all,
at least nothing scientific.
And then he says in his famous 700 page
book called the manual of political
economy, he says, people are
going to misinterpret me.
People are going to interpret me as
saying we should never move into either of
these quadrants.
I'm not saying that,
all I'm saying is we will never have a
scientific reason for moving into either
of these quadrants because if we were to
move from x to g so that we took some,
we tax a by that amount
and we give it to be,
we cannot say,
we cannot say that bees gain is greater
than A's loss because these distances
don't mean anything.
Despite where I put the G,
we just have no way of knowing because
we don't allow interpersonal comparisons
of utility.
And that's the link to the Stevenson
in philosophy that I was talking to you
about. Oh yeah. There's no way of knowing
weather,
um,
B's loss is as big as a gain or the
reverse because we can't make comparisons
across individuals.
There's no scientific way to do it.
We can't assume with Bentham
and with whom and with Sedgwick,
we can't assume that everybody's
basically the same. Perhaps they are.
Perhaps they aren't, but
we just don't know. Okay.
So that is the Pareto principle.
The paredo principle out of which the
hall of neoclassical economic theory was
constructed depends on this idea of
indifference curves. People are trying to,
a is trying to get up
on those investments.
Curb B is trying to get along
on these difference curves. Um,
and we have paredo superior,
righto in Farrier and then these two,
which he call Paredo undecidable
because he can't decide,
not because you're a [inaudible],
but because there's no scientific way
to tell whether in this case B's loss
exceeds A's game. And if we went up
here would be an analogous problem.
Now if,
let's just suppose we,
we go back that a proposes to be swapping
a loaf of bread for a bottle of wine
and they be grazed. They go
to y. And then I says, well,
I'll give you another love red for
another bottle of wine and basis forget it
says, well come on, how about a half
a bottle of wine? He says, okay,
then they go to z. Okay. And if,
if,
if they then get to a point at which
no matter what swap a is willing to
propose,
B says no and no matter what,
swap bean is willing to propose a says no.
Then you know,
they've hit that front here. What's
called the Paredo possibility frontier,
because now there's no way,
there's no way to make be better
off without making a worse off.
Okay, so there won't this.
They will. They will.
What about half of Bob?
What about a quarter of a bottle and
then I want two thirds of alive. No,
that's too much. Blah, blah, blah.
Back and forth. But again, and I'm off.
Okay. No transaction occurs. You
know, they've hit that front yet.
So the Paredo principle says
that in a market system, they'll,
they'll move toward the front tier
and when they get there, they'll stop.
Now of course, they may have gotten
this somewhere else. They might've gone.
They might say,
they might have gone from
x to two g over here,
and then they would have done a new one
and then they might've gone to here and
so on.
And that would just reflect shrewdness
in bargaining or how much people can
lower down there in different scrubs.
Well are the idiosyncrasies,
but once they wind up anywhere
on this indifference curve,
they're not going to move off of it
because now there's no way of improving
one person's utility without diminishing
the next person's utility.
And that is what is called Paredo optimal.
Okay.
So
why is Pareto superior to
x and Z is Pareto optimal,
can be improved upon.
It's an optimum in that sense.
Okay.
That's it.
That is neoclassical economic
theory in a nutshell.
Now I'm going to show you
one more diagram that, well,
possibly look intimidating
when I first put it up,
but all it does is put the preceding
diagrams that we've just looked at
together.
Okay.
And this is, this is what's
in the econ literature, uh,
was invented by an economist called
Edgeworth and it's called an Edgeworth box
diagram.
And let me explain it for you.
Diagrammatically and then
if anybody doesn't get it,
we'll wait up and I'll go
through it more slowly.
But think about the, the, uh,
diagram we just did. Okay. Think about a,
a is in the corner. Okay. But,
but basically now we're putting
the two previous diagrams together.
Maybe I'll just go back.
So was everybody's clear what we're doing.
We're,
we're putting this diagram where we have
to commodities and one person and this
diagram where we have two people on just
utility, we're putting it all together
into one big picture.
And so this is the,
you'll see why this is helpful.
Uh, once we get to the end of it.
So here a,
once an ae has indifference curves,
this is our first picture, right?
So a is trying to go northeast,
we have a, we have wine, we have
bread. So if a is on this difference,
curb the A's difference, indifference
curves are the dotted lines. Okay.
A is trying to get that way,
that way,
that way and keep going all that that way.
Right?
And what Edgeworth did,
and this is I,
it wasn't that I was a
late night or anything,
that I put this writing
upside down. Um, he said,
just imagine a mirror going down here.
Be as coming at it from the other corner.
Okay.
So B
is looking at bottles of wine,
loves of bread, and B is now got
this solid in different scarves.
And be as trying to go this way,
right? B is trying to go this way.
So a would improve if he went this way
and B would improve if she went this way.
Okay, so B, this is an,
this is an indifference curve for B.
Now it's going south west
instead of north east.
Just because it's looking in the mirror
being as, hey, look in the mirror.
Get it. Okay. So B wants
to go this way. As I said,
southwest a wants to go northeast.
So if you imagine,
um,
if you imagine that this were the status
quo from right where a has almost all
of the bread, right? And B
has almost all of the wine.
Then this shaded area here,
this big football is the parade.
Oh,
superior set on the previous diagram.
Because if you think about it,
it's the set that,
okay,
wherever, if you move anywhere in the
biggest football, I've shaded here,
like say we started, let's say we
started here at ECS, wear a hat, all the,
almost all the wine it'd be,
had almost a, all of the bread.
Anything that like if
they went from x to y,
a would be on a higher indifference
curve cause a would've gone from here to
here and be coming the other way would
also be on a hiring difference curve.
And you could draw a new football,
right?
It would be a smaller football
within the bigger football.
And then they, they
haggle again. And I says,
well what about half a bottle of B says,
well then I won three quarters of a love,
blah,
blah back and forth and they wind up at Z.
And you know,Z is on the Pos
Parade Possibility Front Kia,
because every proposal that
one makes the other rejects,
right?
And so you captured in an Edgeworth box
by having their indifference curves be
points of Tangency.
So at z a wants to go this way,
but the only way that a can go this
way would move be off his or her
indifference curve, which is
this one coming this way. Okay.
So all the Edgeworth box diagram
just puts, puts all of the
pictures together. There's no,
nothing conceptually new in it at all.
And it only becomes
relevant to our purposes,
um, because in, in a,
in will enable us to start thinking
about distributed questions,
which I will get to in a minute.
Okay.
Let me pause.
Can I want to be sure if I'd
gone through this too quickly?
Would anyone like me to
walk through it again?
If you think you want me
to walk through it again?
Probably half the people in
the room do so I don't feel
awkward.
It's actually a lot simpler
than it looks, right? I mean,
all you have to do is take the,
the, the previous, the parade. Oh,
principal. Um, the diagramming,
imagine it with a mirror and think
of B is upside down coming toward a,
and then it just all fits together.
Very clever.
Okay. And the one thing I
would say this line here,
okay.
Is One on the previous diagram was
the Predo possibility frontier. Right.
This line is all the
points of tangency between
mmm.
Like there, there is one,
you know, there is one.
MMM.
There is one. So you, you
join up all the points,
points at which the indifference
curves are tangents. To one another.
That is the line where if,
if they get onto this line,
they won't move off of it
voluntarily. Right. By definition.
So they got,
they went from x to y to Z,
but perhaps if they
had gone, you know, if,
if I'm a had driven a
harder bargain early on, um,
they might've gone,
uh,
by a different path and would've
wound up at a different point. Um,
on the,
this, this is the parade.
Oh, possibility frontier,
which Edgeworth called the contract
curve. It's the same thing. It's the,
it's where they will make a contract
to get to, they will agree to,
um, they'll agree to transactions
that get them onto that curve,
but once they're on it, they stay
there. Okay. That's the basic intuition.
So market transactions into the Predo
superior zone and eventually they stop
when things are paredo optimal.
Now let's think about comparing classical
and neoclassical utilitarianism.
If you think back to Monday's lecture
we said with Bentham's utility.
Yeah.
Anything.
This isn't a very good 45 degrees is it?
I guess it is just depends where
you stand with Bentham's utility.
We said that anything,
anything in this whole area,
the first shaded area maximizes the
greatest happiness of the greatest number,
right? That's was his, um,
imperative.
The parado principle.
We now know singles out this parade of
superior area as unambiguously better
because people will go there voluntarily.
So,
so everything that is parade, oh,
superior is Bentham superior, right?
Everything that's Paredo inferior
is Bentham inferior, right?
This is,
this is uninteresting.
It's unambiguously worse whether
you're a classical or a neoclassical
utilitarian,
right?
So everything that's Pereda
superior is bent them superior,
everything that's Predo inferior,
it's bent them inferior.
But now the interesting stuff,
which is where all of
redistributive politics goes on,
and all the battles in politics go
on are in the two Paredo undecidable
quadrants,
right?
This one and this one
about which Paredo says,
as a matter of science,
we can say nothing.
And Bentham disagrees,
right?
Ben femmes principle by sex,
these Paredo undecidable quadrants
because Bentham makes his interpersonal
judgments of utility.
And so Bentham says,
if you go into this area,
yeah,
it's a Bentham improvement though.
It's Paredo undecidable.
Whereas if you go into this area,
it's not a Bantham improvement,
even though it's Prorato undecidable.
So Ben femmes and Sedgwick and you and
the classical utilitarians think we can
make interpersonal judgments,
which allow us to say when it will
make sense for the government to tax a
and benefit B.
Whereas Paredo says
there's no way to tell.
Again,
he says people are going to interpret
me as saying the government should never
redistribute.
I'm not saying that and it's a
misuse of my doctrine to say that.
All I'm saying is if the
government chooses to redistribute,
there's not going to be a scientific
principle to tell them how.
So just to make the point dramatic,
let's suppose we've gone
back to the address diagram.
Let's suppose this is the status quo
that is,
let's suppose B has
everything and a has nothing.
He has all the wine and all the Bragg,
we know they're on the contract curve
because B has nothing that a once,
right.
So I have to thank again
of Trump and the bag lady.
She has nothing that he wants.
So the parade efficient outcome
is for the bag lady to start.
It might not be morally defensible,
but it's the parade efficient
outcome there on the contract curve.
There is nothing you can do to improve
the bag ladies utility that will not
diminish Trump's utility
right
now you could say, but of course
she's on the verge of starvation.
How can that possibly be the case?
But notice we've ruled out interpersonal
comparisons of utility now and so
proponents of neoclassical
utilitarianism have no way
Jamaica interpersonal
judgments of utility.
So the PARETO efficient,
okay.
Transaction is no transaction and
the bag lady starves to death.
Yeah.
You'll see when we come to read
John Rawls later in the semester,
he says,
the trouble with utilitarianism is
that it doesn't take seriously the
differences among persons.
The trouble of utilitarianism says John
Rawls and his theory of justice is that
it doesn't take seriously the
differences among persons.
You now know enough to
see that actually rolls.
His argument is half right?
Because the truth is,
that's the problem with Neal
with classical utilitarianism.
Classical utilitarianism
says, well, if, if,
uh,
taking all of your utility and gives,
giving it to me increases
overall neck utility,
then we should do that because improve
the greatest happiness of the greatest
number. We don't care who
has the utility, right?
So classical utilitarianism is indeed
vulnerable two roles as critique.
It doesn't take seriously the
differences between persons. Right?
And we saw that,
that when we,
you allow interpersonal judgments of
utility and interpersonal comparisons,
you get the radically redistributive
doctrine that Bentham then tries to fend
off with his distinction between absolute
and practical equality that we talked
about last time.
But rolls this point
doesn't actually apply.
The problem with neoclassical
utilitarianism is that
it takes the differences
between individuals,
hypos seriously,
so seriously,
that you would say the bag lady should
starve in this example rather than have
something redistributed
to her by the state, um,
forcibly taken from trial.
So classical utilitarianism ignores
the differences among individuals.
Neoclassical utilitarianism fetishize
is the differences among people to an
incredible extreme. So that proponents
of neoclassical utilitarianism,
like Richard Posner and his book,
the economics of Justice concedes that
it's a problem with you neoclassical
utilitarianism,
that if you have a disabled person
who's not capable of working for anybody
else,
there's no reason or can,
as he puts it contributing to anybody
else's, you tell any function.
There's no reason that that person
shouldn't be allowed to die.
And that he posed to say says, well,
that's a problem with utilitarianism.
And he throws up his hands
and says, I don't really know
what to do about it. And,
and he moves on. It's a deep problem
with neoclassical utilitarianism.
But notice from the point of view
of the history of ideologies,
what has happened in this transition
from classical to neoclassical
utilitarianism.
We've gone from a world in which the
doctrine of classical utilitarianism was a
very radical idea that will legitimate
huge redistribution by the state into a
world in which the radical fangs of
classical utilitarianism have been ripped
out.
And it is now a doctrine that is very
friendly to whatever status quo happens to
be generated in a market system.
So it ceases to be this radically
redistributive doctrine and in the process
imports into utilitarianism,
a very robust,
some would say hyper robust
doctrine of individual rights,
and we'll see how that paid
out in political theory
when we come to look at John
Stuart Mill's harm principle next Monday.
See you then.